so to finish off this morning session in
my mind I kind of see these two talks
it's sort of moving into the future and
sort of moving beyond the ways we've
been thinking about these technologies
and to start that off we have dr. Lynn
Rothschild who's come from NASA Ames
she's a synthetic biologist they're in a
astrobiologist which I think pretty
groovy term and she is going to be
talking to us about synthetic biology
and Mars designing solutions for Earth
thank you very much I was tempted by the
end of the last talk to completely throw
away all these slides and do something
different because I do feel a little bit
as maybe the one fed in the room that
I've been a little beaten up on behalf
of the federal government today and is
this being recorded oh all right well
I'll make it I'll make them good we're
not this monolithic evil organization as
some of you are painting us it's a
little bit more McHale's Navy sometimes
and I'll be happy to talk about it more
in the panel but it's not it's not quite
what it was portrayed and I'll just say
that there was a regulatory meeting of
just representatives of different
federal agencies at NIST a couple years
ago that I was fortunate enough to go to
and that's when it became very obvious
that there's some agencies that treat
one set of organisms as something that
is not as counterintuitive and another
treatment is something else because many
of these regulations have been in place
for a very long time and they don't take
into account things like this and so the
point of the meeting that I went to was
to try to poke holes in the federal
regulations to see where the gaps were
and so there is a lot of work going on
right now trying to fill the gaps and
coordinate and so on but again we're we
are your friendly heads we're not really
the enemy here thank you any questions
so that's my you know advertisement here
so I actually had gone on the assumption
that this was going to be a more heavily
synthetic biology in terms of the
technology so what I'm going to do is
sort of take you back before the first
talk yesterday for those people in the
room who aren't aware of some of these
things that we're talking about and
start with you know what is synthetic
biology and the way I like to think
about it is that for example for
hundreds of years we descriptive biology
what literally thousands of years and
now we're doing synthetic biology
sort of analogy with doing descriptive
chemistry versus synthetic chemistry now
there are all sorts of definitions that
are floating around including talking
about interchangeable parts and standard
genetic elements and engineering
principles and so on but I think this
basic stripped-down definition that we
more or less have borrowed from the
British is as good as any it's just the
design and construction of new
biological functions and systems not
found in nature and what we're talking
about primarily are things like novel
cell components metabolic capabilities
certainly the gene drives that people
keep alluding to CRISPR technology so
editing genes and so on or potentially
making a whole new cell that sort of
stuff that were involved in a little bit
is very much in the synthetic biology
realm a lot of what has been known as
biological engineering was really
synthetic biology there's no point in
you know to arguing how many angels can
dance on the head of the pin sort of
thing now most people work on
applications for the earth manufacturing
environmental control has been a big one
at this meeting
pharmaceuticals fuels materials food and
so on and what I was asked to do when I
stole to start this program is look at
where synthetic biology could be useful
for human settlement primarily on Mars
we always have to see with the new
administration whether Mars is out and
the moon is in or the moon is out and
Marge's in so we try to stay a little
agnostic although the Aries are very
very different destinations and this is
probably as good a definition of
synthetic biology as anything now
instead of giving an acknowledgment
slide at the end I'm giving an
acknowledgment slide up front since 2011
I've been the faculty advisor of a
combined
and Stanford and Brown University team
of undergraduates called an eye gem team
and what this is if you're not familiar
with it is the program that started
about 13 years ago as a class at MIT to
get groups of undergraduates although it
sort of leached into both the high
school now and the graduate divisions to
do a project in synthetic biology
there's a huge competition friendly
competition Jamboree that's been held in
Boston every year this one is fairly
late it's going to be the middle of
November and what the students have to
do is come up with a project do it
including making new bricks they call
them BioBricks where there are genetic
elements that they have to put
standardized parts on so that in
principle they're interchangeable and it
makes the whole field of genetic
engineering much simpler but what's
interesting I think for all of you is
that there is very definitely a human
practices part of this and they're
judged on it and I have to say that one
of my former item or seve is in the room
who's now a graduate student here so she
can tell you privately how awful it is
to work in my lab anyway this
competition being being something that's
fairly open in terms of projects but
being how hosting the team in my lab we
obviously have to do things of interest
to NASA so we started off looking at
using synthetic biology to make a human
enabled Mars colony that was in 2011 and
then we focused on questions of
astrobiology in 2012 and you'll see
various projects from these teams and
that's why I'm just telling you up front
to put in framework that was Eva's team
which was loosely around the idea of bio
communication I'll mention one of those
projects then we made a biodegradable
drone which got a lot of press and I'll
mention some of the aspects of that
project by origami which I'm not going
to talk about but it was a very
successful project and we made a bio
balloon last year which I'm only going
to mention in passing so we've done a
lot of very different things where you
have a proof of concept using synthetic
biology for space applications so why
should you want to do synthetic biology
on Mars don't we have a big enough plan
here well the number one answer is it's
my job I work for the government I had I
was told to do that so I did it but
besides the obvious thing the reason I
was told to do this is because it is
what I believe the only ultimate
approach for human settlement you can go
like the Apollo astronauts did for a
week and I believe I'm already on record
saying you can pack a few peanut butter
sandwiches and come home and that's fine
but if you want to spend the longer
period of time you're going to have to
learn to live off the land which means
something very different off planet than
it did to the Pioneers or even the the
settlers in an earlier generation the
so-called Native Americans when they
came here they lived off the land they
didn't bring everything they needed
forever with them and we're not going to
be able to do that when we move off
planet as well but I want to throw in
this Third Point because I think it's
more relevant to this group and that is
it also provides novel constraints and
freedom from Earth centric concerns and
that includes the sort of environmental
concerns that have been brought up over
and over as well as political ones which
really have not been touched on and what
I'm thinking there is for example I went
to me a few years ago where there were
questions about growing cotton and the
amount of water that it used and we
weren't really talking about transgenic
on and I said well you know you could
always make a cotton plant that doesn't
need as much water could use more saline
water so you can mix the fresh water
with the ocean water and I was
immediately pulled aside by someone from
the State Department and said no no you
don't want to do that you don't
understand that this is soft diplomacy
you want to have the Indonesian cotton
farmers fully employed so that they are
not susceptible to having you know Isis
or whoever coming in you know there are
all sorts of political factors that are
tied in when you make a decision and
then of course the economic factors we
are freed and I'll make this point again
later from terrestrial concerns I don't
have to worry about an indigenous
petrochemical industry because there
isn't one on Mars and so that gives me
the freedom to try things that you might
not have the UNIVAC darwin's wedging
metaphor
you would not have the freedom to try
here so let me set the scientific
background a little bit this is an
actual photograph from the surface of
Mars from one of our robotic robotic
surrogates and I'm asking all of you if
you can find earth in this picture nope
okay there's that little guy there
that's planet Earth and I love showing
this picture because it brings home the
point that Earth is going to be this
little tiny dot in the sky when we move
to Mars or we at least have long sojourn
there and so you won't be able to be in
constant communication it's not like
amazon.com is going to do next day
delivery you know this is going to be
something remote will people think of
this is this little data processing
center in the sky will it be something
that we read about in textbooks or maybe
if you have a particularly you know
elegant extravagant honeymoon you go to
Planet Earth for three weeks I don't
know but the fact is that the link is
not going to be as tight as as we sort
of were imagining it right now so
they're going to be all sorts of needs
for human settlement you need
transportation habitats of course life
support food oxygen and medicine and so
on power heat light and radiation
protections a big one but our challenge
is again are not the economic ones or
the political ones that you would have
on the earth but are things like up mass
and up volume which actually are very
closely tied in with cost so the costs
about ten thousand dollars more or less
to launch a can of coke into low-earth
orbit and at that point what do you have
a can of coke and low Earth orbit that's
not going to get you a whole settlement
on Mars it's going to cost you a little
extra to get it there and so any way
that you can reduce the up mass mass
that you're trying to launch against
Earth's gravity is hugely important and
this is where biology can be hugely
important as well because biology unlike
robotics and so on is self-replicating
self-healing and so on and so in
principle you could take a small number
cells up with you and you can learn to
live off the land say you have
photosynthetic cells they can use the
sunlight there that's free there's
plenty of co2 in the atmosphere it's
about 95 percent co2 and then there's
nitrogen in there so you can fix the
nitrogen as well there's water of course
on the planet it's just not in a liquid
form so you need to melt it or you need
to get it from the atmosphere but you're
better off probably melting it and
they're going to be minerals and so on
in the regolith so the materials are
there for a cyanobacterium or an alga or
something to be able to convert some of
these raw materials into something
that's usable so that's really the crux
of the whole thing is that biology
allows you to beat this up mask problem
also we have issues with storage as a
jokingly said you can't just call
amazon.com and expect delivery the next
day
turns out this joke doesn't work so well
in the UK because they don't get Next
Day Delivery either but you know what I
mean you need to be able to store things
you need to be able to have flexibility
again you can't say whoops I forgot my
pipe patent you better have it with you
or be able to use what you do have and
it better be reliable so these are
completely different challenges than my
colleagues and other synthetic biology
labs have when they need to look towards
Earthlings so what's the big idea well
for millennia we've used biology to do
chemistry on planet earth there is
absolutely no reason we shouldn't
continue to use biology to do chemistry
beyond Earth we may use synthetically
altered organisms for material
production including habitat
construction thought I'll give you some
examples in a moment we may use material
that's brought from the earth to get
started but we may also be repurposing
spacecraft use materials that we find a
destination as the example that I gave
you on Mars was was alluding to or maybe
we pick up materials from an asteroid
and route
we're going to use nanotechnology and
this is kind of an interesting one I get
invited to talk at interesting
conferences including this the opening
speaker for nanotechnology conference a
couple years ago and I must say the
night before in my hotel room was saying
what am I doing here
I couldn't even pass a freshman glass
and nanotechnology and then I suddenly
realize every cell in your body is a
better nanotechnologist that any person
who is in that room because we have to
do nanotechnology at an incredibly
precise level or we're not alive and so
if you use biology to do the
nanotechnology think about making DNA
RNA making proteins this requires
incredible precision or you're no longer
alive so we can use biology do
nanotechnology we may have alternate
biochemistry everyone in this room uses
right-handed sugars and left-handed
amino acids why not make a mirror
organism so we know who our worker
organisms are who's us and who's them
for example we may send coding
information digitally to Mars to make to
make drugs or whatever and this is a
really important point that we at this
point have broken the physical link so
we no longer have to worry about
physically having every sequence with us
we can come up with a new sequence as
our students do every day in the lab our
computer push send that digital
information goes to a DNA synthesis
company and then they send you the
physical DNA so now when you're talking
about sending biological information
digitally you bridge that gap between
Earth and your sequencing or synthesis
company but also between Earth the moon
Mars and so on so that's huge that we
have broken that physical continuity
issue we could actually potentially also
generate electricity from organisms
everyone who's still comatose in this
room is generating electricity from
chemical energy so here is an example
picture I took outside of Edinboro and
you see lots of fantastic biological
products that we use all the time
whether it's wood or wool or meat have
nice lamb
lambshank or whatever now we're not
going to take any of these things with
us they're way too ridiculous to try to
take and there's too much up math we're
going to take something like this these
are yeast cells this is just baker's
yeast that you could get to to make
bread or whatever but you could then
engineer them to make products like silk
or wool or cellulose or latex which
didn't in mine did last year calcite
silica precipitation spider silk which
is a very hot area right now because
it's extremely strong so there are
several companies from the US and Japan
ones that I know that for a fact
that are making spider silk products on
the unbelievable stuff you just can't
domesticate a spider it turns out but
this is again a great product so you put
it in a different form factor so you
take something like a yeast cell and you
now can produce these things off planet
and I have to say that I come from an
evolutionary biology background many of
you know I was actually an undergraduate
at Yale when there was a single biology
department but I would have been
evolution ecology and so I grew up
looking outside at nature and thinking
wow you know look at this amazing
diversity how did it get here where are
we going and so on but then you switch
hats as a synthetic biologist to a more
engineering approach and you look how
plaid and say wow here's this amazing
giant genetic hardware store I can just
start pulling things off the shelves and
doing new things with it and that's what
we're talking about here so for example
habitats again the Apollo astronauts
lived in a tin can for a week and you
can just about do it when the whole
world is watching and it's one week and
then you're going to be home and get a
ticker tape parade it's another issue if
you're going to have a long-term
settlement and even with the current
propulsion systems we're talking about a
year and a half on the surface of Mars
about six months to get there a year and
a half before the planets realigned for
your six months return journey and a
year and a half is a long time to live
in a tin can so traditional ways to make
habitats to bring your spacecraft or
whatever our approach is to take
organisms to a glutamate regolith and
make bricks and once you have a brick
like with this building you can build an
administration building you can build a
lab you can do
and so this particular brick is not one
we made but it's made biologically
agglutinating soils soil actually has a
special definition with organics so
that's why I keep referring to Martian
regolith which does not have the
organics another approach that we've
started exploring and discussed with a
few people last night is the idea of
using micro texture and so here's a
drawing that was produced by an
architect colleague who has a little
firm red house in Cleveland and he's
gotten into the mark micro texture biz
and we put together proposal to make
something like this habitat picture that
you see and the idea is you would have
fungal spores between a double layer of
plastic and then this thing would
inflate on Mars and you would use
cyanobacteria to again convert the raw
material that you would get on Mars into
something that the fungi can eat
therefore they produce these my Celia
these thread-like things that are
basically like fungal roots which can
then be used to harden this shelf so
they basically would be growing their
habitat in place using the raw materials
this is the sort of thing that people
have already started to do and here my
colleagues in Cleveland and you can see
these long form factors that they've now
made fungal mycelium boards with they're
a couple of companies like eco Veda in
upstate New York that it sells
commercial products made with fungal
mycelium chairs actually one of their
great products is a packing material for
wine bottles think about it's sort of
like a completely biological
eco-friendly styrofoam these are not
synthetically altered these are just as
is bio mining we have a fabulous project
going on in that the traditional way to
access metals is either bring them or to
use very heavy equipment and again
you've got the up-mass problem so you
don't want the bulky heavy expensive
equipment but biology is very good think
back to the nanotechnology comments
about very specifically binding metals
and if you're interested in the metals
that we normally buy and look at the
back of a vitamin bottle over 50% of the
proteins in our body use a metal and so
if you can figure out how
to access the ability to bind a very
specific metal and then do something
like engineer a bacterium with that
motif that short bit of the protein to
very specifically bind the metals you
could in principle mine anything
basically with chicken soup at room
temperature it becomes a totally
different operation that little cartoon
shows you what we've been doing is
adding this little metal binding protein
to the flagella of a bacterium so they
could swim through and bind specific
metals we've done copper zinc and nickel
as proof of concepts now what's kind of
cool is that we're particularly
interested in applying that to urban bio
mining which is simply taking metals out
of spent electronics everyone in the
room probably is sitting there with a
pile of electronics so what if one it's
dead instead of going off to someplace
that well places like India and China
and Africa where you can find very
easily if you Google online these
horrific pictures of people with pans of
dead cell phones and so on trying to get
the metals out with the toxin generation
just being really really horrific what
if instead we could take this spent
electronics put them literally in a
blender what you have to do is dissolve
the silica which is fairly easy they're
organisms that make silica PSA's
including sponges and we have now have
transgenic silicates in the lab and so
you're dissolving away the silica matrix
and then you send waves of bacteria in
to pull out the metals and what's kind
of cool is we've buddied up with a group
on the fourth floor in our building
who's making a plasma printer so they
then take the cells that are enriched
for example in copper as the ink to
actually go into this printer to print a
new circuit and what happens is during
the printing process the cells are
dispersed and so you literally just get
the copper because the the organic
matter is degraded because of the plasma
so we then end up with this end-to-end
recycling system for an integrated
circuit and there are two of the people
working on it in my lab right now I in a
dead computer
no one's computers or cell phones will
be safe in the lab at some point in the
next few years so we have to have
everything hidden extra locks to keep
them out
we have done some work with bio plastics
as many other people have as well
microbial cellulose is something you
don't even have to genetically engineer
organisms to do there are a couple of
microbes that make absolutely pure
cellulose cotton is about 95 percent
cellulose and this nano cellulose
actually has other properties that make
it particularly good for a lot of things
including things like wound dressings
and so on we use some of that for
projects in our lab and we sent some of
this process one to the right to the
University of Edinburgh for their I gem
team in 2015 which they then tested to
use for a bio sensor to look for
contaminants in heroin
so we since we're no longer limited by
the form factor to make these products
you can now add something like bio
printing and one of our dreams has been
in our lab to do something like make a
sheet of a feather think about the vein
from a feather it's lightweight and
flexible and strong so what if instead
of just plucking chicken feathers you
could literally make sheets of this
material or another thing that we've
been kicking around a lot is the idea of
printing bone now I realized as the
Neanderthals did make bone habitats my
guest growing up in Connecticut is that
you would have a lot of trouble getting
a building permit for a bone habitat in
Connecticut today that's just a
fictional example in upstate Connecticut
is not literally a bone house an upstate
Connecticut but it is the fabulous
material so imagine you could take the
ability to do this you print cells and
you make a of bone that could then be
used in architecture and so maybe it's
really going to be back to the future
where you can use the ability to make
bone using something like a yeast cell
to actually print materials there now
those are all examples of editing nature
to make a specific product or to recycle
and I find that most people do not have
issues with this I have gotten some
feedback well you know what if the
organisms are loose and if you're
dealing with a biological product like
a bone or spider silk or whatever you're
no longer talking about the living
organisms once you're deploying it and
as I somewhat sarcastically tell NASA
headquarters it's sort of like leaving
your sweater in the car overnight I
don't expect to find three sweaters
there in the morning they're dead
they're sheep products they are no
longer living sheep but now I'm going to
get into an example or two where we
really are editing nature now we're very
interested in life in extreme
environments and that's partly from my
astrobiology background looking for life
in the universe but it's also incredibly
important if we're going to take life
off planet and actually for a lot of
industrial processes on the earth you
may want to conduct them at a high
temperature low temperature high pH low
pH or whatever and so part of the 2012
team asked the question could you make a
synthetic extrema file and this is a
project they call the health cell
project and the name is stuck and I
absolutely love the name and it's
something that we're still very
interested in active in and this is the
group of students from that year you can
see they're very energetic full of beams
and so on so the health cell toolbox
that they came up with and this is for
students out of 12 and a three month
project were a few genes that should
confer desiccation resistance genes or
operons
radiation resistance pH temperature and
cold resistance and being of a certain
age I looked at this and I thought this
has got to be five PhDs and you know
there was no way but they did every one
of them and every one of them helped
push the push the limits free coli some
of this was taken up with the 2014 team
where they were looking actually at
biologically making a platform for
exploration in this case it was a
biodegradable drone we did the balloons
last year with embedded sensors and the
reason I wanted to show you strong
particularly as we started with a body
of this fungal mycelium covered it with
the cellulose that you've now heard
about waterproofed and this is very cool
with taking a protein from wasp it and
you think about it wasp is the one
organism in nature's that chews up wood
and spits out waterproof paper and
that's not
into a senior honors thesis at Brown but
this is the one that then ties in with
hell fell is you want to them have a
biosensor but you don't want to if it's
used on the earth have something that if
it crashes is going to interact with the
organisms here so what the students do
took the ambulance hell fell well the
ambulance mutant that was created
I believe in George church's lab where
it was a recoded cell and then gave it
some capabilities and so the idea is
that if this crash and any of these self
got out it was basically now on a
different operating system than the rest
of nature and so there shouldn't be an
interaction we did not actually fly this
or crash this but this was in principle
exploring the idea and there was their
little prototype that they made so we've
looked a little bit at this question of
why you might want to do synthetic
biology on Mars and the economical also
ties in with the fact that you're doing
an end run and around the earthly
economic systems so let me finish by
just sort of comparing the two issues
one is that we're worried a lot about
human health and ecosystems and again
that's what most other people are
talking about in this conference we
actually have a little bit of that
problem on Mars the moon is is
considered uninhabited and uninhabitable
and always has been in terms of an
indigenous micro biome but Mars is still
an open question and so there are
planetary protection protocols so
instead of going to EPA in the fda
they're International Kosovar treaties
Committee on space research and so that
is actually a concern with some some
bodies in our solar system beyond and we
do have a planetary protection officer
at NASA headquarters the economics as I
said is more of an up math issue for for
Mars for us not the existing industries
but there are things like making wires
out of DNA which one of the AI embers in
2013 did which obviously has
applications both on earth and Mars as
many of these things do making
biosensors either molecular whole cell
or even multicellular can be done on the
earth or off earth and you get colored
readouts you get moving ones I did have
to throw in that one little picture of
our self-folding origami the picture on
the top is a local company in Silicon
Valley
that's making tiny printable biosensors
for the hands and then we're applying
this not just to Mars but the USGS has
us making some of these for looking at
actually avian flu exploration platforms
work perfectly well on the earth as well
as off planet so a lot of this is trans
you know transplant inter interplanetary
but then finally the philosophical
questions and again other people have
talked a lot about whether we should
tamper with life on the earth our big
philosophical question is not tampering
with life on the way for example I
talked to one of the managers about GMOs
and problems with with people eating
them and he just laughed he said
astronauts eat what they're told to eat
that's not a problem
but we are philosophical problems are
what if there is an indigenous life-form
on Mars or was one as my as my
astrobiologists speaking if it turns out
there was a second life-form on the next
planet over and we destroyed it it would
be one of the greatest tragedies I think
in science ever ever ever so we cannot
do that so my final thought was going to
be you know the 10 we should we in which
most people have brought up and I think
that it's still an excellent point so I
decided to add some of these other
questions which I'm not going to discuss
but I'm hoping people bring up during
the various discussions on the next day
and a half and that is what is natural
what is the difference really between
domestication there's nothing that we
eat that we haven't already tampered
with the genome we just call it
domestication is that really different
in principle or scientifically from for
example a synthetic biology and this you
saw before this is basically your
cliffnotes the human ethics so it
answers all the questions that everyone
else is posed thanks
you
[Applause]
[Music]